[Music]
welcome to this special edition of
Hannity I'm judge Jeanine Pirro in
tonight for Sean this week major
developments in several Democrat
scandals including the controversial
uranium one deal and tonight breaking
news about the anti-trump dossier Byron
York who joins us in just a minute is
reporting that the conservative website
the Washington free beacon funded the
original fusion GPS research into Donald
Trump
according to York fusion GPS was also
looking into other Republican
presidential candidates the Washington
free beacon is responding to this
explosive information with a statement
confirming York's reporting and adding
quote the free beacon had no knowledge
of or connection to the steel dossier
did not pay for the dossier and never
had contact with knowledge of or provide
payment for any work performed by
Christopher Steele nor did we have any
knowledge of the relationship between
fusion GPS in the Democratic National
Committee
Perkins Kohl and the Clinton campaign
joining us now is Washington Examiner
chief political correspondent byron york
or a good evening byron ah all right now
you've got everyone talking about what
this fusion gps situation is you've got
the whole thing turned on its head now
it appears at the original funding for
the GPS the fusion gps that we thought
began with the clinton campaign and the
DNC was funded by the Washington free
beacon which is a conservative
publication tell us what you know
it is indeed you know this week we found
out that the whole Russia part of the
Trump dossier the the part alleging
collusion with with Russians was funded
by the Hillary Clinton campaign and the
Democratic National Committee but we'd
always known that earlier than that
several months earlier starting in late
2015 a Republican group had funded
opposition research not about Russia but
opposition research into into Donald
Trump and some other candidates and now
tonight I reported who it was it was the
Washington free beacon which is a
conservative website kind of with
attitude it's it's a it's a website that
mixes journalism and activism and some
of its top staffers have history and
journalism activism and politics and
they're the ones behind this original
Oppo effort
all right so people are now saying you
know who is the Washington free beacon I
mean who owns the free beacon I
understand at one point it was actually
a 501 C 4 not-for-profit it was it
started in 2012 as a 501 C 4 there was a
group called the Center for American
freedom that ran it one of its board
members was Bill Kristol the former
editor of the Weekly Standard is a very
prominent nevertrump voice in our
political debate today and then 2014 it
becomes a private organization and we do
know that Paul singer who is a New York
hedge fund billionaire who's contributed
to many conservative causes is a major
funder of the Washington free beacon
today and Paul singer we can assume was
someone who was anti Trump as well very
much so and certainly in the in the
never Trump camp later endorsed Marco
Rubio
and actually wanted to to somehow stop
Trump at the at the convention you know
there was a kind of a last-ditch effort
to hopefully stop him at the convention
which didn't work so yes the mr. singer
was definitely very anti Trump at the
time this Oppo research was going on all
right and do we know who else was being
did they seek this opposition research
on I understand it wasn't just Donald
Trump that's a good question and the
answer is I don't know they they did say
tonight when the free beacon
acknowledged after my report they they
published an acknowledgement of all this
they said that in the fall of 2015
that's Donald Trump was the lead
candidate if you remember back then in
the Republican race in the fall of 2015
they started this Oppo research project
with fusion GPS looking into what they
called multiple Republican candidates
including Donald Trump so unclear who
those other ones are right now and as
you know going forward I mean the the
Washington free beacon has said you know
we basically did not do any of this
stuff based upon a request by
individuals are they saying who the
individuals are well look a lot of
people there had been a gossip that this
was a Paul singer operation and they and
people had said that he was the one who
was behind all this and I think what the
free beacon is saying is that singer is
a major funder but that the free beacon
has in the past used employed retained
Oppo research firms in its work and that
this was something like that now I got
to say this is not standard journalistic
practice I mean you go to places like
the Washington Examiner or Washington
Post or any other organization and they
don't go around hiring political op op
Oh research firms to do work for them so
this is an unusual situation well
clearly if their investigative reporters
they wouldn't just you know subcontract
someone and opposition research to give
them their information but Byron's stay
with us I'm going to ask that
a few more join us Fox News contributor
Charlie hurt and the American
Conservative Union chair match slap all
right gentlemen I'll go to you first
Matt I mean what what is your take on
the information that Byron has has just
released this evening well there's been
a lot of smoke around this for a long
time and I give Byron great credit
because it just seems like there is
almost an access of political evil here
people who are willing to do almost
anything to stop Donald Trump and there
are some familiar names involved Bill
Kristol who we've all debated throughout
the last two years who was a prominent
never Trump er Paul singer who's put his
money where his mouth is to do
everything to stop them you know judge
the thing I think is interesting is how
did
move from this Republican Africa stop
truck back over now to the DNC and to
the Democrats through Perkins cuy this
law firm there's a lot more here that we
all need to know and you know Byron do
we know anything about that because as I
understand it you know the the original
investigation from the fall of 15 to the
spring of 16 and then it's ended in
terms of the funding by the Republicans
or you know the anti-trump people and
then it's picked up by the DNC in the
Clinton campaign we've contacted who you
know yeah we do know something about
this that you're right the what we've
been talking about this effort starts in
the fall of 2015 and it's a conventional
Oppo research operation that's looking
at Donald Trump's casinos his businesses
charges that he did this or that bad
thing so it's kind of a conventional
opera research and it goes on until
early May and if you remember on May 3rd
Trump won the Indiana primary beat Ted
Cruz in that and essentially clinched
the nomination so this effort stopped at
that point and what we do know is that
after that Glenn Simpson who is the head
of fusion GPS shopped the project to
Democrats and the the Democratic
National Committee and the Hillary
Clinton campaign picked it up and at
some point after that that's when they
hire Christopher Steele this former
British spy and that's when it turns
toward Russia alright and so Charlie
I'll go to you now you know we just
heard that we know that debbie Wasserman
Schultz John Podesta you know go before
Congress with mark Elias the attorney
here from the law firm in question
Perkins Cole through which the money was
funneled before it got the seal and and
so the question is are those two
individuals at risk of having lied to
Congress because they said they knew
nothing about it well certainly the
report reveals something that a lot of
us have known for a long time and that
is what are the incestuous nature of the
way things business is handled in
Washington but I'll be honest with you
for me the doing the Appa research
everybody does our research I'm
terribly concerned about all of that
what does concern me though is that
we've had this past six months
where Democrats in particular or rather
rather the past year we've had Democrats
and particularly the Clintons have made
such a big deal about these Russia
connections and they've never and
they've been lying all this time about
their own fingerprints all over this
completely fraudulent dossier which then
led to the the Obama administration
launching I think an unprecedented
investigation or using the the most
powerful intelligence service on the
planet these vertical right hold it
right you're a madman I see you nodding
your head go ahead yeah yeah I I just
I'm disgusted by the fact that Donald
Trump jr. gets an email about meeting
with people who have information that
he's called a traitor and he said that
he's colluding with the Russian
government Hillary Clinton and her team
went to Russia to shake down the trees
with ladder poot Vladimir's cronies to
get information and there you get away
with calling in opposition research that
cannot stand well and environ you know
you've got a you this whole thing is
based upon that there's the Muller
investigation as well as the unmasking
that came as a result of FISA warrants
are based on this dossier which
apparently is purchased by hillary
clinton and her friends and who say they
know nothing about it which supposedly
costs millions of dollars you know my
faith in the American justice system
I haven't prosecutor and a judge I'm
destroyed by this because right now it's
fruit of the poisonous tree
if that's false everything else comes
down and Muller's got to end it let me
add one thing in addition to the Muller
the factor here the reason we're talking
about this now the reason we learned
earlier this week that it was the DNC in
the Clinton campaign and the reason we
learned today that it was the Washington
free beacon is because the House
Intelligence Committee and the
much-maligned person of Devon Nunez had
had issued a subpoena for fusion gps's
bank records they had been stoned
by fusion GPS before that people had
come before from fusion had come before
the committee and asserted their Fifth
Amendment rights and refused to answer
questions so they subpoenaed bank
records and that has what is shakin this
loose in response in anticipation of
their bank records being handed over to
the house all of a sudden whoa we find
out that Hillary Clinton and the DNC had
funded and now we find out about fusion
GPS so a lot of this is being driven by
the House Intelligence Committee and you
know what charlie to them we certainly
owe they get kudos I mean on Monday
fusion is supposed to respond to a
subpoena handing over the names of
clients their bank records what do you
think Fusion is gonna do absolutely we
own a total debt of gratitude to them
and the big difference here between
today and what we've seen for the past
25 years is Democrats aren't circling
the wagons around the Clintons normally
when the Clintons get in trouble and
when they cause a mess like this the
whole party circles around them now you
have the DNC standing back and saying
hey man we didn't know anything about
this talk to them and you even had
former CIA director Leon Panetta saying
we have to investigate all of this
that's huge time and where's Hillary
where is she
been hiding out you know she's been so
talkative and now she got some quiet
yeah and you know what's interesting is
that once the law firm Perkins Cole who
is the initial receiver of the money's
millions once they waive the privilege
then the focus is on fusion fusion is
now in big trouble
I think it's all gonna start crumbling
Byron again thanks to you what can we
look forward to next week well this is
big this is the next step which is that
the house Intel committee is also
subpoenaed the FBI for all of its
information about the dossier because
you have to remember Christopher steel
went to the FBI offered it his stuff and
they kind of took him under its wing and
and started using this dossier material
in some way so Devin Nunez subpoenaed
them on August 24th he was totally
stonewalled they have not turned over
anything now Speaker Paul Ryan in the
last couple of days
look this is not just one Committee
Chairman this is the House of
Representatives telling the FBI you have
to comply with this request and the FBI
promises to respond next week and that
could be really really big news to see
what they did with the Stasi a
information and what they did with it
and how much Jim Comey knew about what
was going on all right gentlemen thank
you so much